you're blinding us with your power Jenny
I know you're not beautiful eyes all
right you are being honored for your
power what would you tell your younger
self about your own power about anything
you'd wish you'd known how important
your voice is and your confidence we
cannot wait for morning show the
timeliness interesting some crazy
headline I know it almost couldn't write
itself it's sort of bizarre huh
well that affects season two or how do
you think it will affect the way we see
the show I mean it's all sort of part of
the big big global you know world that
we're sort of looking at into so it's
it's we tackle everything it just
happens to be that that's sort of
topical very topical last question we
love that the cast got together friends
we know that we're not maybe gonna get
that friends reboot but could you guys
do another project together how was it
seeing and talking with everybody just
like going home we have the best time
together and we're we always are trying
to think of something to do you know we
just have to figure out what the right
thing is but we will
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]